and you know in those days you know to
answer your question from
quite a bit ago yes i had difficulty
in controlling my emotions i was very
much
as i say first degree i was a bit you
know
all over the place excitable had a very
quick temper you know typically that the
french
blood in me took over the sort of a
phlegmatic british that probably helps
with acting though being able to be like
would you shut the up
yeah yeah yeah yeah do like a hey do a
al pacino you know when he's like
i'm gonna tell her
like he has no teeth exactly hey you
wanna die
you're gonna die big time that's pretty
good
well that was my first gig you know
first gig in the states
when i moved to new york why was doing a
play with al
what play did you do with him i didn't
do my research
and he was herod and for me
for a kid from france you know who
idolized de niro pacino who were you
know seen as gods
all of us to do that in i was i mean
that was not my first gig it was my
first
theater gig uh in new york
that was extraordinary i was
i learned so much from him
and did he ever say anything to you like
hey nice job it was great man
yeah yeah he was really he was lovely he
was really
a really nice man wow very
so you know i've never i've really seen
someone so
imbued with the passion of theater
and acting he literally lives it
breathes it and this is 77 this is like
the height of his like what
not the hype no no no this was in 93 93
oh no sorry yeah i was thinking
because i was quoting carlito's way
that's why i brought it
because you want to die big time was
carlito's way that's when callie is
waiting carlito's way is one of my
favorite pacino movies i have a tattoo
that says blanco and
my grandmother lives in florida her name
is blanche and she's from the bronx but
do you remember he goes hey carlito
remember me benny blanco from the bottom
of the club i always would say hey benny
blanco from the bronx where's my bagel
and cream cheese
yeah so there was a whole thing like
that but carlito's way was one of my
favorite buschina movies
amazing performance by him and viggo
mortensen
oh yeah sean penn do you remember sean
yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah the lawyer or something
legrizamo was benny blanco right
he was benny blanco yeah hey carlito
remember me benny blanco from the bronx
yeah yeah he killed him yeah
yeah great movie beautiful typical brian
de palma but beautiful
yeah beautiful movie but working with
pacino man i work well
yeah but to work with pacino would be
just like a dream any of those
i don't know if i could do it i'd be
like i mean i would do it but like i
think the first couple of days would be
like
i'm talking to pacino what's my line
what's my line but
i was like because you know yokonan is
is in a prison and he's screaming at
pacino you know you're a heathen you're
uh you know he's like in this crazy
state of you know being john the baptist
and
he's and he's a sinner you know herod is
a sinner
i would just watch al because he i've
never seen someone more
loose on stage you know he he would do
anything he would try anything
i would see him like literally do roll
on the floor while
doing his lines he'd done it before of
course he you know he did many
incarnations of of salome but it was
just
fascinating to see him his work with the
prose
with the with the word is extraordinary
you know his relationship
to to objects taught me
so much he would say this because he
would do it
like he said i'm gonna do it like uh
upper upper west side jewish lady
this pen that i have here
he would do these modulations and it
would be so
amazing to watch he had these huge
monologues where
they were fascinating because you never
got bored because he he would literally
have this
he'll be this this will be this ruby
and then he would and he i don't if you
remember he had this crazy
yeah he he was like an over made up
woman
from the upper west side and wow wow
that's incredible did you ever see him
low did you ever see him like
well i wouldn't say the word fail but
like while he's on on
well on set or on stage and he's working
things out and this doesn't work and
he's frustrated did you see those things
yeah looking for richard you mean the
the documentary or i saw him
i mean in real life like did you oh he
in a way you know it's
it's really interesting he reminds me of
that saying by mandela you know
uh i never lose either i win or i learn
uh which i love which is one of my
favorite sayings by
uh nelson mandela because
you never see him get mad he's always in
relaxation
that's every time i see al pacino
you know maybe younger he was more tense
you know but it's this
inner tension you know when you see him
in dog day afternoon it's
it's like watching a ballet it's this
incredible relaxation that enables him
to access something that
where he never fails so he'll try he'll
be like i remember him being on his
all fours with hands up in the air like
i have a ruby
and you know he would just try
you